So I'm still here in Utah in Park City.
I'm here for the wine festival.
I'm here to cover it for their social media team.
But I wanted to talk about some of the, like,
rumors and misinformation
I'm seeing spreading about Western North Carolina
happening on the internet.
And listen, TikTok can be a wonderful place to spread information.
It can be a wonderful place to get the word out.
It can also be a great place for people to follow down
rabbit holes of conspiracy theories.
I've been seeing things about lithium mines,
about bulldozing the town of Chimney Rock,
about the fact that the government sent the Hurricane
or that somehow created it.
Marjorie Taylor Greene had a tweet that said, like,
of course they can control the weather.
No, that is insane.
I've seen people saying, uh,
this is because they wanna wipe out all of the red voters
for the election. Those people must have never been to Asheville,
because Asheville is a little blue dot, okay?
Those people are more hippie than the people of Burlington, Vermont.
Okay, granted,
the surrounding areas probably a little red,
but storms are not politically motivated, okay?
Storms are natural disasters.
Nobody, no matter who they vote for,
deserves that to happen to them
or is being punished for their politics.
The only thing that matters is donating,
getting money to the organizations that are working up there
and getting supplies to the people that need it.
Okay, there are Tons of local organizations that are organizing.
Churches, restaurants,
um, the World Central Kitchen.
Donate, help. Don't spread crazy shit.